sur cette vidéo authentifier et
circulant sur les réseaux sociaux un
ouvrier matraqué par des agents de
sécurité vêtus de combinaisons blanches
la police anti-émeute est aussi présente
car depuis près d'un mois l'usine est
confinée sous haute surveillance
impossible pour ses ouvriers de quitter
les lieux
éprouvez cet ouvrier brise les vitres de
locaux administratifs un autre arrache
une caméra de surveillance les violences
se sont poursuivies durant la nuit
est la plus grande usine d'assemblage
d'iPhone au monde si grande qu'on la
surnomme iPhone City la grande majorité
des travailleurs réside sur place dans
des conditions souvent dénoncées comme
les heures supplémentaires obligatoires
et le manque d'équipements de protection
très importante parce qu'il y a à peu
près 200000 personnes qui travaillent il
faut dire aussi que la campagne foxconne
emploi en tout près d'un million de
personnes en Chine août c'est ces
problèmes là cette usine là il y a eu
également des manifestations à guangzho
à Canton et je pense que tout ça
pourrait continuer de dégénérer
plus du quart de la population chinoise
subite une forme ou une autre de
confinement des règles sanitaires
drastiques même dans des villes non
confinées comme Shanghai presque tous
les endroits où on doit accéder que ce
soit des centres d'achat aller au bureau
les transports publics ça nécessite
d'avoir fait un test spécial à l'Inter
de 48 heures les tests PCR et le port du
masque sont obligatoires d'autant plus
que le vaccin chinois est moins efficace
que le vaccin ARN messager
chinoise
d'admettre qu'il faut changer d'approche
à ce statut ce serait
une perte de face pour le Président
c'est une ping la politique du Zéro
covid menée par la Chine semble sans
liser et aurait un impact économique
dans les chaînes d'approvisionnement
mondiale est en train dans d'être miné
parce que les campagnes européennes les
compagnies américain il y a plusieurs
qui commencent à regarder pour aller
ailleurs la Chine a annoncé récemment de
légers assouplissements en réduisant la
période d'isolement des voyageurs trois
ans après le début de la pandémie le
pays compte près de 30 000 nouveaux cas
de covid par jour ici Radio-Canada
Montréal